now who do you think for instilling the
sense of fashion in yet to be honest my
very good friend Jeremy language
it runs mr. Porter always encouraged me
and inspired me I suppose
and as the most stylish man do you have
any fashion regrets
absolutely white jeans was a mistake I
shan't make again white anyway we put
the white jeans away I have to give you
a huge congratulations it has been quite
a year for you congratulations on the
Eternals super exciting gotta ask you
how excited are you to know be with Kit
Harington again little mini game of
Thrones reunion show to it with Kagan
Jimmy John and Angelina Jolie and
someone hanging the whole cast is
standing bunch of actors and Marvel
confirm that there's going to be a
character a part of the LGBTQ community
how important is that inclusion I think
it's hugely important just now just as
they care cast is so diverse that you
know that I'm white male actor that's
not in the majority in this case were
actually the minority which is really
important in terms of diversity in
filmmaking I think the Marvel are really
in the forefront about and really
congratulations on Bodyguard nomination
any update with the season 2 cuz I'm
keeping my fingers crossed and nothing I
can talk alright now watch the space ok
we'll catch you soon thank you
[Music]